[Music]
kayla starts off this hour in boston hi
kayla welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure how can george and i help
so i'm just having trouble with my
monthly budget um i've been budgeting
for a while but me and my husband seem
to
not be on the same page with this one
little thing and it's
when you're
so say
your first paycheck doesn't come until
the middle uh like six days into january
would you still put
the items you're buying like groceries
and stuff into december or would you put
that into january even if you haven't
been paid in january yet
so you're saying you have a line item in
your budget and the funds won't be there
in time
no so we have money that we haven't put
into our savings account yet we have
leftover money
and money that we budgeted for
but
so my husband's saying when
um i buy groceries on january 2nd say
then that should be in the january
budget
even though
um we haven't started the gin like we
haven't gotten paid in january yet ah
does that make sense yeah well that's
okay i mean you can use the money that
on your december 31st paycheck and
that's going to fund part of january
right
right so we're just getting confused
because we're both doing different
things so i don't know if there's a
better way to yeah you can't both do
different things right
that right there tells me there's a
bunch of breakdown you don't have two
budgets you have one
right and we have the same every dollar
account so
when we're putting things in it's just
getting messed up and i just wanted your
help to get us on the same page because
we both love you so yeah
we appreciate that so um yeah
number one whatever we do we both have
to be doing it both of you doing two
different game plans is going to screw
up the math as you probably already
discovered that's going to cause a
bigger fight though actually
yeah that's going to be a bigger fight
than anything else you do so but the uh
so so the way we did it is
um
it's okay to set up january's budget and
have some leftover money from december
to fund until the first check comes in
january but january if you buy food on
january 2nd that should show up in
january's budget
it should show up on the second that you
bought food now where did the money come
from well there's money in your food
envelope left over because you knew you
weren't going to get a check when you
did your december budget and so you had
money to fund into the first week of
january does that make sense
yeah yeah it does that's what my husband
was saying but i i was over complicating
i think
so
in your case if you said
uh
i mean the problem is is that everything
is set up on a monthly basis
if you were just running it week by week
uh or are running it not counting the
first of the month
uh because you're not getting paid first
and 15
that wouldn't be unusual but but the the
every dollar software doesn't run that
way and it makes it really hard to keep
up with
it really runs on the calendar right
right right yeah and that's what we
usually use every dollar yeah you said
that so that's good thank you and it's
good it's good software it does it's
very robust it does the job but yeah
you've got to figure out a way to cover
it kind of like um
if you got paid at the first of the
month
but your cable bill comes um towards the
middle before the second check comes
then you wait to pay the cable bill
until out of the second check you don't
pay it out of the first check because
it's right up there on it
right makes sense
yes it does thank you okay hey that's a
really good question here's what's
really important about it the details of
the answer don't matter what matters is
two things one is you're actually
freaking using a budget
that is huge that's huge
and the second thing is that you are
engaging
you're engaging in your in your
relationship
and you're doing it with your husband
otherwise the fact if you had not had
this conflict because you either weren't
doing a budget or you weren't doing it
together and bumping into each other
that would be a bigger danger sign than
the nuances of this answer it's almost
semantics and the fact that you guys are
on the same page both doing one budget
together willing to do it that's huge
but
dave we run into this occasionally and
it comes down to having a little buffer
you know we're not saying with
zero-based budget doesn't mean you have
zero dollars in your bank account that's
a good point too and so having a little
buffer in there can really help some
people like to get a month ahead uh if
that's something that you can do and
that gives you some some peace to say
hey we've got you know two thousand
dollars in a checking account this is if
you're later on the baby steps but that
can sometimes help couples get over the
the idea of we're going to run out of
money mid yeah what you do need to set
is some kind of a buffer and just make
that your baseline we don't go below
that in the checking account uh except
in dire situations but i mean at least
keep like a hundred dollars in there you
do not want to run the checking account
on zero balance
you don't want to overdraft because
you're gonna be running down to zero all
the time you're gonna bump into stuff
that's not that's not good so you need
to keep some kind of a buffer in there
and that's your baseline and you never
go below that you treat that like that's
zero you know if it's a hundred bucks or
fifty bucks or a thousand bucks whatever
it is we used to in the old days that's
a thousand years ago we keep a thousand
in there at least
because that got free checking if you
left a thousand bucks in there i don't
even know what it does now i don't keep
up with it that close in terms of what's
free i've got so many bank accounts and
so many things here now but the uh but i
mean and we keep a lot more on a
thousand in checking these days but the
the point being that we that was our
baseline that was the the floor yeah so
to speak we wouldn't get down below that
very very good question that's very
important thank you for joining us emily
is in portland maine emily i'm not going
to get to you i looked up and saw the
clock i'm going to bring you back up a
little while so george what we've
learned this budget thing in this every
dollar thing is really important because
we've learned in
almost ten thousand people over six
seven thousand families going through
financial peace university the highest
correlating behavior with success
meaning if you said
dave tell me one behavior that's gonna
cause me to become successful doing the
things in financial peace university
meaning getting out of debt being
generous becoming wealthy the number one
thing that we see and there's not even a
close second is couples doing a
zero-based budget the way we teach
together
using every dollar yeah the ones that do
that
their their results are head and
shoulders above everybody else
they're like well i'm going to take the
class and i'm going to issue this and
ish that we don't really do a budget and
then you wonder why i got it in my head
or i do a budget but it's not a zero
based
or i'm not using the every dollar app
because i don't like that
you know
your results are like one-tenth of the
people that actually do that one thing
properly so her question is really vital
yeah great question on paper on purpose